welcome back everyone to my channel here
on firm learning this is the christmas
edition of firm learning so welcome to
another coffee break indeed a merry
christmas to all of you i feel honored
that today i have my sister with me here
yes hi i'm karolina i'm henry's sister
and i'm joining him for this new video
i'm excited first time on the channel so
it's a pleasure calling you know please
be nice to her in the comments because
what we have planned here for today is a
little
christmas edition a personal edition i
hope that this will help you better get
to know me and also the other way around
if we have some conversations about this
in the comments because what i asked you
to do on the instagram is to ask me a
couple of
personal questions personal things that
you would like to know about myself and
i screenshotted all the answers and sent
them to cowadina so she has them all on
her phone now so i trust she will now
pick a couple of the questions that you
sent me and um let's see what uh what i
will answer to that and columnar you
agree that you didn't tell me in advance
what questions this would be right no i
didn't tell him in advance so it's going
to be a little surprise for him um
surprise surprise so let's start
first question um who inspires you for
your success and creativity
oh that's that's a good one and here
frankly i think there are many people
who do inspire me probably both on the
personal and on the professional side so
i had the
the pleasure to work with some extremely
inspirational motivational people over
the course of my career over the last
years i don't want to say any specific
names but there were different several
past colleagues or some project leads of
mine partners of mine that i worked with
and that i really enjoyed working with a
lot
some other friends of mine who i meet at
university who i regularly see you know
founded some startups other careers or
some very inspirational people
and for sure lots of things that i've
heard from these gentlemen and ladies in
the past okay
how did your first marathon go
my first marathon was
i believe 2017 or 2018 or so in paris
so i ran the marathon in paris there
i wasn't much of a runner before i the
the furthest thing that i could do or
maybe 10 kilometers or something like
that
but that was quite a stretch for me and
then it was actually my wife who
motivated me to do a half marathon she
was always much more of a runner than i
always was and so then i remember that
about a year before this marathon we
signed up for a half marathon in munich
and i managed to do that then this way
and then i got some confidence that
probably if i could do the half marathon
i would also be able to then run the
action marathon and so over the course
of a year i did some training practiced
and in the end yes i made it in paris
and then one year later i ran the
marathon in munich
and then i wanted to then also the year
after do another marathon so my idea was
to run my one marathon a year but then
the whole health situation prevented
that and then the marathon got cancelled
and now frankly i'm a little bit out of
shape so probably for the new year
resolutions for next year this is one of
the things i need to tackle so so how
many marathons did you do in total now
uh two two okay i saw but colleen i know
that you are also currently running a
lot yourself
so probably some things that i should uh
learn from you and get inspired from you
but pretty far away from a marathon i
think that steps yes
um
okay so you spoke about your wife
already so now the question i think
everyone is kind of asking themselves
how did you find your wife
yeah so i'm together with my now wife
already for many many years i met her in
the beginning of the university
and it was um actually on ordinance plus
which is quite a big like place
everybody from munich we know it and i
met her actually after oktoberfest so i
was on oktoberfest you know how this
goes like leather trousers some beer and
so on and then afterwards we left and
then we were all leon splatz and then i
saw like a random group of of ladies
standing there i was with some friends
myself as well and then we approached
them and this is how i got to know my
now wife
so you just talked to her i just talked
to here with a little bit of confidence
from drinking the one or other mars at
oktoberfest the locals trust know what
i'm talking about that gave me the
confidence to approach them and talk to
her and
yes many many years ago and then
two or three years ago now we got
married
so how many years ago was that in 2019
2019. nice
okay um that's a german question so um
which topic are you educating yourself
on
currently
so
it's a good question right and i mean
during my current role at building radar
where i currently work as a chief
revenue officer one of the topics that
now i'm focusing more about which of
course also heavily relates to what i do
at firm learning is online marketing so
currently i'm learning a lot about
online marketing
copywriting
creating
sales funnels sales structures this of
course is a big important topic also for
building rape and what we do here from
learning as well
so yeah currently lots of books under my
my bed about these topics
and you like to listen to them right
some also on on audible this is a
service that i use to listen to them but
some also in the written printed book
format nice
um what brings you joy in life
oh wow that's that's a philosophical
question
and
even though i did study philosophy um
many many years ago and i have a
bachelor of philosophy i think this is a
question that's often very difficult to
answer but in my specific
situation given that this year our baby
girl was born the answer is of course
quite easy
so we feel so blessed that since april
actually of this year we have a baby
girl that's part of our young family and
of course she brings us joy every single
day even though it's of course not
always easy and sometimes also quite
tiring
she's more than making up for that
what have you learned about yourself
since you
since having your daughter
um what do you think about did i did i
change in any way since i have a
daughter
not really i think
um
not not much um
actually no yeah i mean it's it's an
interesting question right so do you
change
because you become
children i mean
surely your priorities shift and surely
now this is a new big responsibility of
course that you have in your life
and surely now you have to think about
new things that you didn't need to think
about in the past so a couple of days
before we decided to actually take the
train here to the rest of germany our
girl was sick right so we wondered can
we now do the train ride because she
wasn't feeling well and thankfully she
recovered in time of course this is a
new layer of complexity that we didn't
had before
but i must say beyond these smallest
obvious things
i don't feel like
life completely changed for me to be
honest now
what's your advice on work life balance
and balancing career aspirations with
family
needs i mean here for sure this is one
of the things where your perspective
does change also after you become
children so i remember when i was
working in consulting
it was very common for me no problem at
all to
obviously work late in the evenings i
remember my first internship that i did
in consulting i spent with the team in
the office it was like the first or
second day and then around 7 or 8 p.m we
decided to go for some dinner and i
thought yeah sure why not let's let's
have some dinner with the team and then
i was
eating something
and then i must say i was a little bit
surprised that then after dinner
everyone was going back to the team room
so we're going back to the team room and
continuing to work there probably this
is just a sign of my ignorance that i
didn't inform myself enough before i
applied for this consulting internship
um but at that time that was normal that
wasn't a problem at all for me and
frankly i know many people also with
family that decide to continue this
career path but the truth is of course
that uh many people also once they get
children then at some point decide that
maybe this is the time to spend a little
bit more time home with your family with
your children because
of course it's great to also see them
during the week see them in the evenings
and
this was not the main reason why i left
the firm the consulting firm because
that was already when i didn't have a
child
but surely now thinking back and when i
was the working consultant having a
child at the same time that would have
been quite difficult
okay um so
then this is like three questions and
one
first what drives you second what are
your pillars and three how do these
pillars impact you and your decisions
um
here probably also the truth is
it's not that i have
these big drivers where i could say this
is where i do the things that i do the
pillars if you mean this like like the
virtues the values that drive you
so here i think i would struggle but one
thing that i that i really like it's
part of an organization i was part of as
a student in germany you say lieston
initiative
foreign i feel like this is
quite strong of a group of words so
leicester means
probably perfect performance
means derived initiative and for unvoil
means responsibility i find these three
pretty good and sound principles that
you want to follow right so of course
the things that you do you want to do
well performance
you don't just want to do the things
that you're asked to do but also have
some initiative be proactive right think
about practically yourself what are the
things that you want to shape and build
and create in your life and then third
of course responsibility at some point
is the question
are you responsible of course for your
family for society
can you transform the things that you do
to become the force for good in any
sense i think these are questions
very well worth to be inquired
nice something i can learn here as well
um
[Music]
new patagonia vest which one do you
recommend
so i think yesterday i posted an
instagram story and then i got some
questions on this new patagonia vest
indeed my wife gave this to me as a
christmas present so you see here not
sure if you can see it this little firm
learning
embroidery here
um
so i like patagonia that's quite a lot
but i feel like at some point especially
over the last one or two years i'm a bit
afraid they like became even more of a
cliche that they all they already were
cliche
so not sure if i can really continue
maybe you shaped the cliche i'm not
trying
i don't know but i think they look very
cool it's also really nice under a suit
maybe you know also in the team room in
consulting just to stay warm uh then at
some point you can you know take away
like the the the upper part of your suit
and then just wear a dress shirt with
the west at least this is something that
is very well accepted also of like in
the because lighting forms also if you
were client side
and it's somewhat maybe a bit also more
comfortable and comfy and maybe the more
traditional suits set up so i i i like
this and probably there's not the reason
why many other people like this as well
what's the best advice you would give to
a business student coming from your
experience maybe then personal advice or
i guess it's really surprising it's
probably important to
and given that i know that many people
watching this channel are interested in
consulting it's important to probably
understand rather early whether this is
a pathway that you want to do
because surely if your goal is to join
one of the you know big leading
consulting firms
you need to really move in that
direction as fast as possible right so i
mean this has to do with grades that you
need to
write so some level of academic
performance this has to do with with
some internships that you need to make
also the right cadence of internships i
mean you do need to transform also your
curriculum detail your pathway in the
direction
and
this level of activities and of
performance is maybe not needed if you
are also interested in another career
path
so probably it's really about
understanding what you want to do rather
early on and then moving in that way
and then of course there are many other
things you can do as well if for
whatever reason this is not what you
want to do
and i guess that's also very fair and
you can have a fantastic and fulfilling
career following some of these other
paths as well
um
i think this that's a because there were
a lot of obviously career questions and
should you do an mba career advice and
we don't want to cover that for this one
so many more questions to uh
yeah to cover in the following q a's
so thanks for joining um
i guess literally all right that's it
thank you very much for watching
thank you very much looking forward to
many more videos with you eradina let me
know in the comments whether you want to
have more videos with carolina in the
future thanks to all the members of from
learning as well i will include the
names here somewhere
merry christmas to all of you enjoy the
festive period
and a good start to the new year and i'm
looking forward to many many more
helpful videos in the new year so stay
tuned for that all the best new videos
on this channel every single saturday
cheers bye-bye subscribe